this is Queen Elizabeth oh and I really
really really want her crown Sandra this
is really the first time you've done an
animated voice performance like this has
no one ever asked you before I did one a
long time ago but it was very tiny what
was it and it was call is called Prince
of Egypt of course on story of Moses
which people ran to see um and then and
then I had done none after that so that
led me to believe that maybe my work
wasn't something that Sarge interested
in the end material so I was very
appreciative and grateful that they came
back and and thought they it was ok to
give me a second chance yeah it is in
its heart it is hard work if you have no
idea how to sell an emotion with your
voice without using your hands or your
face or prop or another actor uh-uh no
but I gonna do a bedika na papaya I've
studied Spanish French and Latin so I
definitely heard a lot of bits of
different languages in the minyan speak
how do you guys decide which actual
words are going to be spoken because I
hear banana and I hear pleas it's really
tricky in the sense that on the first
despicable me I I didn't write anything
i was just like improvising and it was
gibberish and on despicable me to the
minions sort of became part of the main
storyline they were stolen by this evil
guy called el macho to be used to like
against grew at some point so i had to
make the language evolved a little bit
and the way it evolved i'm very sorry to
say because it's very low-tech is a
every time i had lunch and was somewhere
i would steal the menu and then would be
in a source of inspiration and so the
tikka masala the papadum there she's
done what's harder to wrangle minions or
kids Oh minions for sure cuz they just
don't listen and they don't understand
me nor does my son apparently the suits
of death doesn't lessen as well yeah
minions for sure I don't want you to
take this the wrong way but I hate
this is torture guys cut it out this is
really unprofessional